[Music]
it makes sense news not Dallas submitted
by Erika Tran hi [ __ ] Tran a novelist
who wrote how to murder your husband was
charged with murdering her husband Wow
we've heard a story like this before no
the other one was where this dude would
write about how to kill that's right and
then he usually killed someone
damn this that means that the world this
is very common in the world that's scary
I know is this in the news
yeah Musa the six plays in Portland why
would you do that why would you write a
book about it that's cocky food-truck
capital of the world why is her husband
missing oh maybe it's this book she
wrote she got inspired by OJ Simpson huh
why I didn't do it no if I if I did it
and do you see the cover for the if is
like this is this [ __ ] big I did it
it's great roaming in and everyone's
made well the publisher did that he
didn't do that are you sure he drew it I
know they drew it sign off I'm pretty
sure it was on Adobe and he was sizing
it and he like I'm gonna feel small
he's like control T transform yeah so
this woman her name is Nancy 68 years
old she was recently arrested on charges
of murdering her hood when did she
murder him and she really did murder her
it was recent though because they
recently figured out that it must not be
a good nom I thought maybe she got away
with it like for 30 years and then she's
68 it was a few weeks okay oh oh she
didn't write a very good mystery huh so
she is a romance novelist who's written
she's been published at least seven
times Wow making ladies all kinds of
orgasms yeah does that mean anything no
one in the Amazon publishing world that
we live in but being published doesn't
mean that any more of this yeah there
now yeah I'm not you could be if you
wanted to yeah just submit just write
the rampage
into a book there you go coffee table
book G oh the coffee table book I'm in
I'm buying that I'll pre-order yes get
your book right now I haven't done it
yet but I'm gonna cross the title the
coffee table book deal the coffee table
geo the coffee
the : yeah yeah oh I love this
collaboration guys I love it and then
you can check out my coffee table book
it's called McGee's but I've had entire
secret super pictures of Nikki's but
secretly for at least five years now or
I'm gonna scrap it you'd be like hey hey
hey can you pick up that towel over
there dude you have no idea I get so
many sneaky a shot I always see it weird
and like I always sit like this and she
doesn't know it but she's the most
sexual being on the planet I've seen it
yeah and the way that she sits is like
she wants to get [ __ ] that way oh my
god all their hormones are [ __ ]
raging on and so I have so many secret
shots of her but it's insane so I'm
gonna do a copy of vagina lips a couple
times oh yeah really tasteful click yeah
in your book outbid his or outsell his
so it's in my book - oh no wait how did
you do it nobody buy any of these I just
got snaked know she has tits and Cydonia
kind of these proceeds or else I will
I said I'm giving you a cut everyone
gets a cut even Joan I promote Geo's but
you do tits all do ass so you get the
tip mark and I get to ask market I'm not
it could be your book where like the
front page is the tips and then you flip
it over in this yes this is why you're a
genius tip that's why you're [ __ ] you
she just cut me out of the deal again -
you're out plumb whereas you can do your
own aptitude there's probably better
than hers
[Applause]
this is like cardi B versus Nicki Minaj
and all over
I don't care I paid for these I worked
for these two okay in a different way
why did you pay that's all that matters
you paid them off you paid them off this
tip is [ __ ] ever oh I actually want
to hear the story all right so she would
write books of our relationships that
was wrong but never felt so right and
then so in her book the wrong cop she
wrote about a woman who spent every day
of her marriage fantasizing about
killing her husband and the wrong
husband a woman tried to flee him
abusive husband by faking her death and
then in how to murder your husband which
is an essay she wrote about how to get
away with it so she would describe five
core motives and a number of murder
weapons that she would choose if her
character were to kill a husband in one
of her books and she would advise
against getting a hitman to do the dirty
work because quote an amazing number of
hitman rat you out to the police I
should drive you how does her husband
Mike check in with her about work he's
like so what you working on oh yeah
what's it about oh about that show we
just every day she did some on kill
Rosalyn that's great that's great you
want some chili oh do you know he was a
chef today boo yes Louisa she killed oh
and let me tell you some work so they
and I she would against hiring a lover
to do his dirty work because that's not
a good idea and poison is not good
because it's traceable
she's like who would want to hang out
with the sick husband so what's the best
way to kill and they she said if the
murder is supposed to set me free I
certainly don't want to spend any time
in jail so she was really careful about
she doesn't know what the voice weapon
is cause she got caught yeah what did
she end up going with though no she
ended up doing was she showed up to his
workplace which is the Oregon Culinary
Institute in the morning before his
class began cuz he would he was a chef
that would teach people how to cook and
he she fatally shot him and then
students had started going into the
class for the class and saw him bleeding
in the kitchen around him leaving out in
the kitchen and then police didn't have
any evidence oh yeah like yeah there's
no description of a suspect or anything
in for a few weeks she was a suspect
because one of her neighbors that have
known her for six years he asked her
like hey so are the police keeping in
touch with you like have they found out
like who would do this to him or like
anything and she was like no but I'm a
suspect
and then the neighbor was like I thought
she must have been one tough woman to
handle it the way she did oh yeah but
she just had no like she was like thank
goodness but in that how to murder your
husband I say she did say that she
although she frequently thought about
murder she would never she could never
see herself going through with it
because it's so brutal and that she
wouldn't want to worry about blood and
brain splattered on her walls or
remembering lies she finds it easier to
just wish people dead than to actually
kill them what kind of psycho so she is
is not claiming up like she's not
admitting to guilt not yet know what God
the investment is there anyway we know
they got yeah I'm not sure
okay don't mention that oh so she's only
a suspect
oh no she's been charged and everything
but I just don't know what it is I got
her who did it to her the
I'm ready for 27 years in case you guys
were here she waited a long time she
should feel like to [ __ ] Holden that
much deep hate toward your partner for
that law I don't even think it's deep
hate I think it's like just a fantasy of
kurios oh shoot oh that's a good goal
it's like she's obsessed with if the
book is right then he's been abusing her
super yeah Oh cuz when she say her core
motives were cuz like if it was like oh
either my husband does this or oh that
would be so sick if he's been like the
perfect husband yeah she's like I'm
bored I want to kill you or like Nicky
says it's just a fantasy like a weird
fetish but if there's a fantasy that
means after this if she gets away she
gets another husband she'll probably
kill that one too right just cuz that
gets her jollies going I don't want no
matter what it's not right because it's
like gone girl
remember gone girl oh yeah it's like
whatever like he cheated on her but then
she like did all this [ __ ] it's like oh
my god it's just she back or something
yeah oh damn she looks like she wakes
her mouth looks like someone on purpose
like pinched it really small her jawline
looks like McDonald's French five bucks
[Laughter]
me and Isaac have a picture like that
what a chicken what the fair this is
handier chicken chicken he looks way
younger than her it looks like her son
yeah he's a fighter he was a 6300
cradle-robber
68 she does she looks like she's eight
yeah it's all it's from all the stress
and wanting to kill people yeah so her
solution is to wish people dead all the
time I wonder how much she thinks of
that like I've never met anyone that
like thought of like hoping that your
people that are close to your dot like
dead all the type of teenagers I've
never known
anyone she was like fantasize about it
all the time but it would just be too
hard to keep up with the lies so I guess
I'll just wish people dead you know it's
like new you always think I don't think
about anyone that much to wish anyone
you know I hate you I mean I'm just not
thinking about anymore I don't even
think about you right yeah you don't
exist to be dead I know I haven't I have
I have fights with celebrities that I
don't even know in my head you know I'll
just be like I just you know like
politicians and Cher like you being like
people like man I can't believe you said
that [ __ ] because if I was there
I'd say something different I would see
the better a lot of people do that [ __ ]
do you think do you guys think I'm
twisted because when I was younger and
like there were people that I really
hated in my life instead of wishing them
down like that's too [ __ ] easy
you should be tortured yeah I think no
we all do that now that's normal it's
normal
yeah we do that now it's very normal
[Music]